mentally and emotionally tough the life
they've lived the father they've had the
experiences they've had it's it's it's
almost like that's preparing you that if
you do go through something like this
they can't break you they're going to
try to break you how are they holding up
purely mentally and emotionally uh uh
themselves I I'm sure knowing him how
competitive he is and how annoyed he is
and how much he likes to be in control
like a lot of business CEOs we
understand that DNA and the fabric of
wanting to be in control and now you're
not so there's a part that's driving
them and saying but also you see him
when he's walking around he's always got
the Quran in his hand so I'm assuming
he's praying a lot so he's trying to
work on this how how do when you talk to
them how are you feeling their energy
they're they're where they're at
you know the the energy is remarkably
positive in light of where they're at
and what they're going through I think
they just have tremendous resolve and
strength and that's both mental and
physical and emotional strength so I
think they're doing the best they can in
the situation they're in to stay
physically strong I know they're you
know continuing to exercise and work out
and do what they can within the confines
of being in jail but to stay physically
strong at the same time as you said they
are praying meditating
um they receive a lot of letters and you
know fan mail so they they read those it
keeps them you know occupied so they are
the one you know they don't complain
about boredom it's more about just this
intense frustration of having all of
this going on you're you know
proclaiming your innocence you want to
prove your innocence and you are in a
jail cell where you can't you have no
means to do so so you know you're
putting a lot of trust obviously in your
team and your attorneys
but but it's very frustrating to be in
that situation I think again under the
circumstances
um I think they are holding up quite
well even though it's very challenging
I I bet but but again I think if there's
anybody that could do this the two of
the guys together you know one time I
think Tate said you can take everything
away from me as long as you don't take
my brother I'm gonna be okay you know to
do the way the father raised to get
these two guys to be as close as they
are that's probably giving them a lot of
strings by the way are they in the same
seller are they keeping them separate
where they can interact with each other
or be around each other
uh I I know that they they do interact
um I'm not I'm not actually quite
certain about the cell situation because
I think that's changed you know over
over the detention period so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]